Earlier on, we looked at solving equations which looked something like this.
Here, we have 3x plus 4 equals 19. Let's consider something slightly different
however. What if instead, we have the equation y equals 3x plus 4, let's say
that we want know the value of x when y is equal to 19. Well, we know on one
hand that we can just use substitution to replace y here with 19 and end up with
the equation that we saw before. Then, we could isolate x and have an answer for
it. We can also however use a graph to figure out the x-coordinate when y equals
19. Please use this graph to find that x value. Also, please take note of the
scale of the x-axis versus the, the y-axis.
On the y-axis, every grid line up counts as 2, whereas, on the x-axis, it's only
1.